hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's now I know I said it was pretty
much done with this but somebody by the
name a big bug decided to do the
impossible and beat 2020 2020 mode on
this game and it's amazing incredible
congratulations Sam for getting at first
I'm using his strategy and basically
what you need to do is you need to put
the right door down every single time
you put the camera up and watch foxy
very closely and may as your power and
be perfect in general so I've been
practicing this for many hours if this
seems rather tired of me to say this it
is absolutely that because I've been
playing this over and over and I've done
that introduction many times over I'm
tired my wrist hurts my brain hurts it's
oozing out my shoes right now I want to
win this so badly and yet I don't know
how I am trying so hard and even if when
I am perfect and even when I get to the
end and even when I have a chance to win
I lose because it's random like it's up
to random chance sometimes and I hate
random chance because I hate when it's
just it's not entirely dependent on
skill because that means that no matter
how hard I try it's every possibility
that I could lose every single time if
it's random like that I don't like that
so I apologize if my commentaries a bit
stale or pessimistic in regards to my
chances at beating this sometimes but I
have failed more times than I can
remember I have so much footage of me
just failing over and over again oh and
he's already peeking out his curtains
that is not a good sign I know I'd like
to stay positive about this but frankly
I've gotten so close so many times and
I've had it within my grasp only to be
robbed from me by a stupid mistake or
Freddie being a douche err
or someone else just generally for being
awful
more specifically me being awful at this
game but I mean it's so incredibly
incredibly stressful I cannot even say
I'm remotely scared by anything that
happens in this game now but the
pressure the pressure to be perfect
every single goddamn movement you make
needs to be perfect and absolutely
spot-on and just fantastic and I'm tired
of talking and I probably shouldn't be
talking because why makes me lose a
little bit of focus here but it might
help you never know and I apologize if I
grow silent sometimes but that's just
the way it's gonna be there's no way in
hell I'm gonna be able to beat this if I
don't focus on certain moments and the
only thing that I need to do the only
thing that I guaranteed need to make
happen otherwise I can't win is wanna
manage the power but to make sure foxy
only hits my door once because each time
he hits my door he Rob's some of my
power and I can't do that if he hits it
twice I there's literally no way for me
to win and I can't do that either
I can't leave lights on
I can't stress things like that I can't
follow the rhythm I I have to always
focus on represent the entire time I
play where else I'm going to lose that's
just the long in the short of it dammit
he's already leaning on towards a sprint
I got to keep him there but I also gotta
manage my power so it's like a balance
between checking quickly spending enough
time in the camera that he's satisfied
and just generally what he feels like
because he can change attitude whenever
he wants like I've been playing it so
many times and I've failed so many times
that I've noticed that he has no strict
pattern like I can look at it so very
often and will get it not off and he
could not move a bit we could not do
anything at all this is I wish I could
say that I was an expert at this game by
now but it's this far in I still don't
know what the hell to do sometimes all I
can hope is that me pushing these
buttons in a certain order well great
that's fantastic
he's already on its way okay the best I
can hope for is that the second I'm
around he's gonna be a bit lighter but
given that he's already peeking out from
his curtain I'm gonna guess that is a
negatory
not doing well on power as well as I
would have liked anyway sleeping stuff
on making mistakes getting sloppy it's
not something that can keep up I gotta
take this
as far as I can go dude was he already
mine okay chica hasn't been very active
with them again she never is up there
she has never mind the devil
oh if I could just win like a just win
once just once even the developer said
that this was probably impossible he was
surprised anyone was able to beat it
good for you developer oh boy I'm gonna
get a second head no matter what now I'm
gonna get a second that it's stupid like
sometimes it's I'm doing the exact same
thing I almost always do and I wish I
could say I knew the pattern but I don't
matter how often I do this matter how
hard I try I am still boned
every single goddamn time
right bring the whole family if
everything is going great except for
foxy being a [ __ ] I would be able to
win
come on pace to win right now I'm on
pace to make time but he's just gonna be
a son of a [ __ ] and he's probably gonna
charge my door again can't say that I
blame him
god I wish he was less of a douche
I want to win really badly he's gonna
charge my door again isn't he he's gonna
do it he's gonna slam his booty into my
door I'm not gonna like it I don't like
it
come on without a little longer
it's a little longer
okay all right okay
Oh cut I'm cut I'm cut I'm out I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out come on come on
come on
don't kill me foxy I know you were about
to sprint down the hall but I know
there's a bit of time I have left
come on oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh oh go down quicker power
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh oh yeah hey everybody shut up I gotta
take a long time Freddie please please I
beg of you
I begged every fiber of your delicious
fluffy body please let me have as much
time as you could give me please take
your sweet-ass time
okay finish your long-ass song please do
not kill me instantaneously please
0:03 stars oh okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
just finish this stuff quickly just in
case like the game crashes I lose game
footage I don't care what happened I did
it oh my god I can't believe it I am
crying right now
you don't understand what seven hours of
five nights of Freddy will do to you oh
my god they're those like the worst
commentary I ever did on the last one
but I don't care I did oh my god I did
it I wish you could have been with there
with me throughout the every single
attempt I can't even talk right now
oh I'm happier than what I beat vanish
oh I'm so happy I'm so happy I'm so
happy oh thank you all so much for
watching and believe it could be you can
check out my playthrough the other five
nights of Freddy in the five nights at
Freddy's playlist over there check out
that new horror compilation again and
please you know a nice comment down in
the comment section would be nice for
support cuz I really have been trying so
damn hard oh thank you again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video